IBM API Connect provides a model driven
approach leveraging the loopback
framework to create api's in this
tutorial I'll show how to create and
test api's using API connects API
designer if you have not already
installed API connect on your laptop
please refer to the previous tutorial or
product documentation and install IBM
API connect on your laptop before
attempting these steps to create a
loopback project go to a terminal window
and type API C loopback - - named API
connect demo this command will generate
several questions we will accept the
defaults name of the application API
connect demo name of the directory where
the project is saved API connect demo
and the kind of applications hello world
this will create my API connect - demo
loopback project and I will return to
the command prompt we will change to
project directory API connect - demo and
run the command API C edit to start the
API designer the API designer opens in a
browser window log in using your bluemix
user ID and password click on the got it
button on any informational pages you
see click on the API API connect demo to
explore it in the design assemble and
source tabs the design tab is for
designing your API the assemble tab
allows you to assemble enforcement
policies for AP is the source tab
provides the source view of an open API
definition or API Swaggart definition to
test the project we need to start the
service first the service can be started
either in the API designer or the
command line in this tutorial I'll use
the API designer in the API designer
click the Run button on the bottom left
of the screen to start the micro service
and the gateway service once the
services are started you will see the
status of the services on the bottom of
the screen along with the IP address and
port numbers
now we will test the API by clicking on
the api's tab and selecting the API API
connect demo we will click on the
assemble tab to open the API and
assemble mode and the invoke assembly
will be open by default here we have the
option to test the API click on the test
button and we will be able to select an
operation to test click on operation to
see the pulldown items and scroll down
until you see message greet select
message greet and scroll down in the
navigation pane until you see the
invoked button click invoke you may see
a digital certificate related warning as
the certificates common name is not
localhost review and approve then click
invoke again for a successful invoke you
will see a status code 200 under
response in the navigation pane and the
greeting message under body this
concludes the tutorial on creating a
loopback project exploring its API is
starting the service and testing the
project by displaying the stored
greeting thanks for watching